hey what's up I'm Kim BHD here and did
you notice something I've been thinking
a lot about this over the past couple
years of watching Apple presentations
and it just became much more obvious
watching their latest which was WWDC
because in this presentation Apple went
through 45 minutes on stage talking
about their New Vision Pro headset and
they didn't say the words virtual
reality on stage once and just in
general there are certain words that
Apple just refuses to say or generally
doesn't like to reference at all in any
of their presentations or any of their
marketing and it's fascinating to watch
so what are those words and why is Apple
doing this so let me start with the why
now obviously I'm not Apple so this is
from the outside looking in but there
are two really good reasons for why they
do what they do or why they don't say
what they don't say and those are
control and comparison so control first
I've already talked about Apple a big
reason for a lot of what they do is
being able to fully control over
everything as much as possible and that
extends to PR2 or it doesn't even have
to be PR it's just smart branding but if
you come out with a new product and you
associate it heavily with a word that
the general public already uses or that
another company some competitors are
already using heavily for a bunch of
different things
then you run the risk that the sentiment
around that word might actually change
and might actually have a downturn at
some point in the future thus dragging
the whole reputation of your product
down with it so here's another commonly
never used word in apple presentations
AI Apple just doesn't say Artificial
Intelligence on stage now if you want
some contrast go back just a few weeks
ago to Google's developer conference
just a Google I O and they introduced a
bunch of features on stage in Android
and in Chrome and let's just say they
weren't shy about what was powering it
as an AI first company ai ai ai
generative AI generative AI generative
ai ai
a-i-a-i-a-i-a-i-a-i-a-i-a-i so I mean
pretty clearly they love leaning into
that but apple on the other hand also
introduced at their developer conference
WWDC a bunch of software features in iOS
and Mac OS and they use the words AI or
Artificial Intelligence on stage exactly
zero times
they never said it now they did use
phrases like machine learning and ML and
they talked about how a Transformer
model is being run local on device that
will help auto correct in the new
keyboard in iOS 17 things like that but
at no point did they call themselves an
AI first company or proudly Proclaim
that they have a bunch of new features
powered by AI to show us today nothing
like that and I think that's because
clearly AI is such a big thing that it
kind of has this public Persona that
also has a bit of a dark side it's got a
it's a bit of a controversial word in
some areas we've talked about how AI art
is sometimes accused of stealing from
real artists I made a whole video about
that I'll have a link below
um and so the word is so much that if
you're appleing you care so much about
your Public Image you don't want to risk
attaching yourself to that word that you
can't control
so they just don't they literally just
don't say it so that's control
uh the other thing like I said is
comparison and this is a funny one too
with Apple so if you've ever watched an
apple presentation which most of us have
there are some pretty common themes that
you see every time you see the high
production value a variety of presenters
unlabeled graphs Craig's power stance
but as a tech reviewer one thing I've
also noticed and I think any other
journalist or anyone covering these
companies probably also notices to a
point is that Apple just kind of avoids
comparing themselves or even talking
about or acknowledging other companies
or other products at all they kind of
just like to pretend that they are the
only company in the world and they exist
in this little ecosystem of just Apple
stuff and other stuff just sort of Fades
away now there are a few notable
exceptions to this rule like they do
every once in a while mention oh our new
laptop is X percent faster than the most
popular PC laptop or something like that
they'll do that once in a while but
really in general they do it far less
than the other companies especially
actually have watched it a lot in the
smartphone space if you watch another
smartphone product unveiling a lot of
them will do straight up spec
comparisons to others and like just
number comparisons you know our folding
phone has a new 4 800 milliamp hour
battery which makes it the biggest
battery in any foldable in this category
oh our new phone has a 200 megapixel
camera which makes it the highest
resolution ever in a smartphone oh our
new display refreshes at 165 Hertz
making it 20 percent more responsive
than the next best thing all this stuff
Apple doesn't really like to do this
type of comparison instead they would
much rather name
everything now I'm not just talking
about the products of course they name
things like the iPhone and the mac and
the airpods and the software also has
extremely functional names you have iOS
iPad OS Mac OS wash OS TV OS Vision OS
but they also like to take technical
achievements and Technical features and
brand them put a name on them they name
everything so instead of 120 hertz High
refresh rate ltpo display we've got
promotion instead of an optical
fingerprint reader we have Touch ID
instead of a large linear vibration
motor it's a taptic engine instead of
the latest version of glass from their
supplier it's ceramic shield now of
course everyone knows the value of good
catchy branding but when you brand
something for yourself instead of using
the term that everyone else uses that
specifically makes your version a little
bit harder to compare to everyone else's
so while all the other companies are
talking about okay we got to 120 hertz
but now we we've got 244 Hertz and now
our gaming phone is 165 Hertz So it's 15
more responsive than their 144 Hertz and
Apple's over here like we have Pro
motion and this version of promotion is
more responsive and smooth than any
other Pro motion we've ever had like
they hardly ever use ip68 or IP67 on
stage as much as they just like saying
it's dust and water resistant again and
there's hole punch cutouts in the top of
the AMOLED display of every other phone
in the store but ours with our software
on top is a dynamic Island there's
actually a whole page of these just on
Apple's site I'll link it below just
just trademarked names of things that
they've put their stamp on some are
programs some are features some
technologies there's a lot of them
clearly they're not the only ones who do
this but it's just the most consistent
thing about all of their presentations
and the cherry on top of all this is a
lot of times Apple doesn't even really
like saying at all ever what the actual
spec is they'll leave it to you to find
out later and Tech reviewers are really
digging and figure it out but when's the
last time you ever saw the milliamp hour
size of an iPhone mentioned in the
Keynote
last time I checked they just don't do
that ever they'll just tell you it's the
longest battery life of any iPhone we've
ever made that is the epitome of control
and comparison now with the New Vision
Pro headset that Apple just unveiled in
particular it's interesting it's really
interesting I made a whole video just on
I got to try it and my first impressions
with it if you somehow haven't seen that
yet I'll link it below
um but it's also pretty clear based on
what we know that Apple has future plans
with this to make it cheaper of course
but to also make it smaller and higher
Tech and better and better to the point
where the tech sort of just Fades away
and you have a pair of glasses that you
look through and still have all the
technology and function from so they
never really want to call The Vision Pro
a VR headset even though it totally is
because of the Ambitions that they have
to steer this this vision and the
control that they have no pun intended
towards mostly AR stuff so you'll see
all kinds of Demos in the videos of a
virtual reality headset with really good
pass through like when you go into that
theater demo for one like you're in
complete darkness with a huge screen in
front of you I mean that's literally a
VR headset but they want to steer you so
much towards thinking of vision as an
augmented reality experience and that's
much easier if you just never say
virtual reality out loud at all the
closest they got was talking about how
you can spin the digital crown and fully
immerse yourself beyond the dimensions
of your physical room with features
called environments
and there it is they've managed to Brand
virtual reality with a different name so
they can control it and manage what it's
compared to over time they also didn't
say a whole lot about the specs on stage
part of it of course is because this is
something that's coming out uh early
next year so it's not done maybe some
things change between now and then but
they still didn't say a refresh rate on
stage they didn't say a field of view
number in degrees like they avoided a
lot of the things that pretty much every
other VR headset and maker out there
would put in their presentation but
there was no shortage at all of naming
things and setting the tone for how they
want us to think about this headset
going forward so the next time you're
watching an apple presentation or some
keynote there's a lot of impressive
things to pay attention to you know the
graphics the transitions the Drone shots
the power stances
but it's the words
pay attention to the words
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace